well it's clear that the risks to the
world economy the risks of the British
economy of this standoff between the
eurozone and Greece is growing each day
and I think the risks of a
miscalculation or a misstep leading to a
very bad uncle come what is growing as
well and so here at the g20 we are
urging all parties to this dispute to
try and find some common solutions and
we're also at home stepping up our
preparations for whatever the outcome
maybe we have to make sure that the
British people are best protected from
whatever develops in this crisis because
I'm clear that the Greek exit from the
euro would be very difficult for the
world economy and potentially very
damaging for the European economy we
have to be prepared for that outcome so
we have to make sure that we choose a
path of competence and stability over
potentially chaotic and disorderly exit
so the repercussions for the UK economy
could be harmful well there's no doubt
that the UK economy would be affected by
a crisis in the eurozone we know that
from recent experience that's why we
need to take steps to protect ourselves
at home and that's why it's right that
we step up our contingency planning it's
why we absolutely vital that we go on
working through our economic plan so
that we are taking steps to secure and
strengthen our economy but the idea that
Britain or indeed the rest of world is
entirely insulated from what happens
here is any sadly not true now of course
Britain's membership of the European
Union is very much a hot political issue
and this is an election year here in the
UK George Osborne told us he wants
Britain to stay in a reformed EU with a
referendum on membership by the end of
2017 we've made it clear that britain
wants to stay in a reformed European
Union the European Union needs to change
that continent where jobs are created
and prosperity is created we also need
to make sure the relationship between
members of the you who aren't in the
euro
like the United Kingdom is a fair one so
those are our priorities going forward
and we say we will put this to the
British people in a referendum we said
that that referendum will take place by
the end of 2017 but as the prime
minister said earlier this year if we
can conclude the negotiation so you know
we'd be delighted many investors have
voiced concern that an earlier
referendum could potentially speed up or
cause an exit what would you say to them
to measure with them first of all
there's been a lot of talk often in the
media that somehow our European policy
might deter investment the truth is
since we said how about policy we've
continued to receive a huge amount of
investment into the United Kingdom more
than much of the rest of Europe but
together and we're now a real go-to
destination for international investors
because we've got a competitive tax
system we've got a skilled workforce
it's a great place to start and grow
business so our European policy is all
about making sure that the whole of
Europe is that a place where business
can grow and jobs can be created and as
I say what we want to achieve is Britain
in a reformed European Union a European
Union that is an economic success story